hello keep common hackathon hai free
code camp my name's Jane Sorensen and
this is the first video that I am doing
for you all and I had pitched the
article to Quincy quite by accident back
in September when I was starting to
create a product and I had no idea how
to do a landing page and no idea how to
do online marketing and I wanted to be
able to just do something quickly with
my WordPress and Quincy said if you're
having a problem with this
chances are other users are too so I
accepted to do what you're about to see
if anything is confusing bounce through
my six thousand word article and ask a
question either here on the video if
it's relevant or on the article if it's
relevant now there is a product that I
release on a monthly basis it's a
digital download I called the tactical
chronograph and what it is is it's a
monthly agenda that you print out at
home and you can carry it around by the
by the week or carry around the whole
month agenda so you can plan your time
accordingly because what you put into
your phone calendar isn't always
sufficient for for planning and keeping
track of everything that you want to do
so I came up with a nifty design
basically responding to my own needs and
I started marketing it using this
landing page that I'm taking you to
right now what we have here is we have a
pop up it's probably a time to pop up
that will go away before I click the X
there but I've figured out a way so that
simply by subscribing to my email list
then they click yes I want the tactical
chronograph I will automate an email
within my email list that will then send
them the download link so that they can
get the tactical chronograph directly
from the link rather than order it in
the shop and then click the link to get
the download so this is two ways by
which people can collect what I'm giving
them for free
so closing out of that this is my
landing page the back end of how this
works
MailChimp and WooCommerce
WooCommerce is the e-commerce website
web services that are provided for
WordPress users MailChimp and WordPress
and WooCommerce have an API that
connects together so that if somebody
uses a word rule commerce to order my
product and they go through the
traditional shop download there is a
little check marks button for them to
subscribe to my email list
MailChimp the MailChimp API will
recognize that that person has
subscribed to the list through
WooCommerce and also which products bill
they have bought so that's going to be
able to queue them up in my email list
for any type of automation where I could
say people who downloaded the tactical
chronograph I would like them to have
this particular email campaign then
there's also the form and other
integrations so this is where you will
do the majority of your work here is
where you will design a little form that
you can use at the bottom of any of your
landing pages or any of your blog posts
where it just makes it really short and
sweet subscribe to the list first name
last night is your typical default for
it
this you have to have connected if you
are using WordPress to go into too for
WordPress and MailChimp to speak
together
here despite gdpr
I do have usage tracking on usage
tracking it is a requirement for
MailChimp for those who have fewer than
2000 users and therefore are using the
free account now what this really
entails is that you will know when
somebody has clicked open your email I
don't really get any interaction through
the WordPress interface as to what
happens between MailChimp and WordPress
just that MailChimp knows what product
they have ordered and then when I have
sent them a campaign according to the
product that they have ordered or
according to any criteria I can see when
somebody has opened one of my emails and
when they have clicked one of the links
the logging and Erin Warner's warrant
things only that's for WordPress
developers so that would be you and
that's the screen where you have any
errors so let us go over to MailChimp
and see what they are looking at here
project akka is the list I have for this
particular website and let me just see
if I can create a segment based on
information that came from the word
chimp and blue commerce integration so
contacts that match all let me see now
I've made my list for projects akka
because it has a global audience GDP are
ready however probably only two or three
subscribers have opted in while under
the new GDP are regime so I won't look
at those now because that would just
merely be a curiosity here we go orders
let's see total orders let's see if
anybody has ordered two of my products
when I really only have three goose egg
that means that of the people that have
come in through the store they've all
only ordered or the word ship MailChimp
and WordPress have noticed that they
have ordered one product create a
segment let me see commerce purchase
activity has purchased pregnant yes so
we have 33 people who have come in
through my will commerce store for one
of my products on project ACOG I hope
that gives you a little bit of an
overview as to how we're WordPress and
and MailChimp has connected themselves
together so now let's go back to doing
an actual landing page so in June and
some of us have had our time off this is
copy I'm gonna change what better time
than to do a little reflection on what
you wanted to get done with your year
here's where I'm gonna add some media
I'm just gonna add a placeholder a bit
of media I'll just choose this
particular image there insert into the
post
we will Center it
say in the caption placeholder for
20-second explainer video you can
subscribe with this no caps is needed
queued to receive it and no time now the
reason why this link works is because in
that segment that I showed you earlier
when I created this segment to test
different people I have created a
segment called the new hustle chrono
opt-ins let's take a look at what I
called that new hustle chrono opt-ins
means that after the last email campaign
was sent on May the 5th May the 4th the
signup source to get the product was
through the generic API which is the
hustle API connecting to my MailChimp
and hustle is a plug-in on my wordpress
and i set it up through that that if
they were ordering the chronograph that
new subscription was going to stick them
in a group a project group called
chronograph so new subscription where it
was immediately added to the group
chronograph gets thrown into this new
segment so all new subscribers with that
will then start receiving this email and
go back to the website
this link presently I'm going to send
them to mailing list which I don't have
but I do have a code given by MailChimp
for WP for the forum so we'll save this
draft
we will grab this shortcode right there
then we will go back to the post just
simply use the back button for it
and we're going to drop the form at the
bottom of the blog post say sign and
bake letters remember these are going to
become a button and we're going to
create an anchor for it a name equals
sign up and I'll just perhaps get the
syntax wrong and have to diagnose it
later
here we go subscribe to the email list
link
so there's the anchor there's a link to
the anchor let's do a preview
there you go see that little shortcode
popped up subscribe right there all they
have to do is enter first name last name
email address let's create a segment
where not so much date added as in
landing page activity the landing page
activity is MailChimp specific landing
page a service that they offer and I'm
gonna briefly show you that as well but
instead we're gonna choose sign up
source API generic MailChimp for
WooCommerce and we're going to add is
after a specific date now I'm not gonna
be making this page live until say
Saturday so we'll add Saturday and here
we go I'm now going to show you
something that MailChimp has about the
landing page service of their own
because sometimes having a landing page
that is not hosted on your own website
you don't need to have WordPress you
could be using bootstrap you could be
using Joomla or Drupal or Weebly or
wicks or Squarespace although I'd love
to give spare Squarespace to try they
probably have that covered and native
weight very well but MailChimp has a
landing page service and I started one a
little while ago to give a chart test as
to how it works and here it is a
tactical chronograph landing page you
design the landing page oh that looks
funny you design the landing page
exactly like you would be designing a
email in within mail chip and here the
GDP our marketing permissions this is
new and so simple content is what the
standard tactical chronograph front
cover looked like up until June and the
June covers gonna be different a little
example of what it looks like when
you're using it and hey this is your
call to action grab it drop it right
here and it's your email and go so
that's a really dead simple landing page
let's preview it use this space to tell
see you're supposed to write some copy
here
free t-shirt or a downloadable PDF
that's exactly what we're doing
send me the link that looks pretty nifty
I like that I like that when it's
actually completely done but I really
like how dead simple it is here's a
cautionary tale though watch out for
your graphics see how the background
graphic just blows away everything else
but at least you have the hero image
your call to action your persuasive
argument and your email collection and
gdpr permissions send me the link I like
that let's publish it
remember it's not actually fully
published until that link is out there
for somebody to find and click so there
is no risk here in doing this
save and continue' and we're gonna add
your page title and say so this one is
test and page tests landing page means
nothing to the public let's give it a
test test web page people want to manage
their schedule and diary because it is a
diary as well a little better save
that is an awfully long Earl I can edit
it you want to have something short this
is what I was talking about earlier
where it was just slash chronograph
instead of a slash technical Kanna graph
because people want to type in very
short comprehensible URLs so we're gonna
take off people here I'm just gonna say
manage schedule diary better short
memorable still kind of long
take out the diary in fact schedule is
also a verb so we'll take off manage
there we have a nice short Earl so the
test web page for people want to manage
your scheduling diary a little better
there's the Earl for it the contacts
will be added to project akha let's edit
that yes to project a car but it doesn't
allow me to add them to a subgroup yet
that again would be the segmenting where
they recognize landing page activity the
content has already been designed the
reCAPTCHA is enabled so let's just click
publish
hi-five it's live i either will be able
to edit it later or I'll be able to
replicate it but now I could create an
ad if I want to for Facebook and I
already have an automated welcome email
set up for everybody who joins the list
like I said you should have a Thank You
page that that your web page redirects
to when people successfully signup but
they should also receive a confirmation
email to make sure that they are
confirming to the list and then a
welcome email that comes after the
confirmation email that will include all
links to any free content that you're
providing them so back to the list
projecting uh and we're creating a
segment this one is going to be yes it's
auto-update by already landing page
activity I'm gonna say not just any of
the following conditions landing page
activity they signed up on the tactical
chronograph landing page or date is
after a specific date May 25th
let's see if there's anything else I
want to add to that and I already have a
segment for those store however like
it's still added in here and that
doesn't change anything in the results
it's a product purchased is the tactical
chronograph we only want people who are
subscribing to it new so for now with
just the date added it's gonna have to
be a dumb list where we're gonna assume
that everybody who joins the list after
this date until the next time I go in
and change the segmentation rules we're
gonna assume that they're ordering the
tactical chronograph this time it's
gonna come back with zero I'm gonna save
it as a segment we're calling it the Jun
TC automated segment and put to check as
a note to self that sometimes somebody
will land in here when they've ordered a
different product there we go so my list
has a few different saved segments
chrono through whoo after me seventh
those people who ordered it in the store
new hustle chrono opt-ins that's for
people who ordered it through the pop-up
that isn't working right now right yet
this is a different product and the one
way and this is just anything that they
ordered through the store if they check
the little SUBSCRIBE box they get into
that segment as well so I hope that
makes the the process of signing up to a
mailing list through WordPress as well
as using MailChimp a little bit clearer
and some of the important things that
you are going to need such as
connecting the api's together
understanding what your products are and
how they can be used to segment a list
if you have any comments questions let
me know you can always reach me through
my own website which is projector co.org
you're welcome to also join my tactical
chronograph group because everything is
free and I'm looking forward to doing
more and better videos like this one
thanks very much I and by the way I just
wanted to mention who you see in the
background particularly Taylor right
there and somebody who's putting
together a 3d printer I have been
working this whole time out of the
technology sandbox at Concordia
University and I love it here and I love
this giant Mac if you can find a space
to work and it like a makerspace like me
go for it